Superman's history on the big screen
spans decades starting way back in the
serials in 1948 and eventually
culminating in the acclaimed Richard
Donner film that pretty much everyone
loved but since Donner was fired from
Superman to the past few decades haven't
been kind to Superman cinematic exploits
from the failed throwback adventure
Superman returns to the off-again
on-again Man of Steel sequel there's
some reason to believe that DC may never
actually make another standalone
Superman movie again too good
being a goody two-shoes hero may have
resonated with earlier generations but
in today's crowded superhero field
Superman falls behind a pack of
characters far more nuanced than the
heroic super alien good stories need
conflicts and while there's plenty of
super-powered bad guys to fight and more
than enough special effects to go around
it's the internal conflict that tends to
set a good movie of heart from a
mindless blockbuster when it comes to
Superman
kryptonite isn't his biggest weakness
it's perfection he's so good that it's
hard to really have him struggle with an
existential crisis and it's those kinds
of stories that help audiences connect
with a character mana feel tried but
ended up with a moody emo Superman
instead good really two powerful Marvel
seem to learn this lesson faster than DC
sometimes your most famous characters
don't quite work as leading men in
Marvel's case it was hope after two
mediocre movies they figured out he
works best against the biggest villains
in the biggest adventures like the first
two Avengers films Superman has a
similar problem having a hero who's
pretty much unstoppable makes it hard to
set real state sure he may get banged up
and bruised but how many times can a bad
guy without kryptonite there's not
supposed to be that much of the stuff
just lying around after seven movies the
most well-known danger to Superman has
been played out team-up trouble the days
of solo superhero flicks are numbered
even the ALS heroes like Captain America
aren't alone in their franchises want to
get past the origin story and almost
everyone has super pals tagging along
heck even Deadpool brought along
colossus and negasonic teenage
onic teenage warhead for the ride in his
first solo outing comics are all about
crossovers so it's no surprise the
movies have followed suit the first sign
that Superman may be relegated to
co-star status was the 2015 news that
Man of Steel 2 was reportedly put on
permanent hold while rumors swirled in
late 2016 that development was back on
there's still much more speculation than
concrete info it seems DC may be
planning to just use Superman as part of
its larger ensemble film they can still
tell Superman stories but dawn of
Justices box office performance proof he
doesn't have to carry a full movie by
himself money talks a film studios
decisions almost always come down to
money specifically how to make as much
as it is possible and DC's Trinity of
Wonder Woman Batman and Superman are
arguably three of the most famous
superheroes in the world but elbow three
Superman and Wonder Woman have always
played second fiddle to the Dark Knight
but simply every Superman movie put
together has made around 2.3 billion
dollars while just 2 of Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight movies cracked a
billion dollars on their own yeah that's
a lot of cash I'm only warning my half
that makes Batman the fourth most
successful franchise in all of film
behind only Star Wars James Bond and
Marvel yes Superman certainly factors
into Warner's plans but Batman has
always been the cash cow don't expect
that to change anytime soon
packed schedule there's also the fact
that Warner Brothers has DC movie
scheduled out through 2020 and a solo
Superman movie is nowhere to be found
everyone from cyborg to the flash and
even the Green Lantern Corps are getting
their own movies over the next few years
and the first Green Lantern flick was
pretty much a disaster so DC has more
than enough on its plate without trying
to find something else for Superman to
do in the mean time but if the studio
ever does figure out how to finally make
another truly great solo movie with the
Big Blue Boy Scout well that'd be just
Superman thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]